um
file this under musical covers we never
knew we
always needed courtney cox giving us her
best cover of olivia rodrigo's driver's
license
on sunday the former friends star shared
this clip to instagram
[Music]
yeah that's the 56 year old actress
totally crushing her rendition of the
high school musical the musical the
series
stars hit track on the piano
[Music]
but seriously i want to buy that album i
thought it was incredible
court shared the clip to her stories
tagging olivia and
asking how'd we do and she captioned the
video of her tickling the ivories quote
even my dogs love this song
and you know what olivia she loved it
too
it was so good the 17 year old musician
slid into the comments to praise the
actress
writing yes slay
um where can we sign the campaign for an
olivia courtney duet
100 but olivia wasn't the only one to
give court
mad props suzanne summers was literally
all of us
writing omg so great and sting's wife
actress director trudy styler said it
like it is
writing simply gorgeous but this isn't
the first time
courtney has showed off her musical
skills last february she shared
that clip playing alicia key's underdog
which was co-written
and co-produced by her longtime love
johnny mcdade
and in october the actress and her 16
year old daughter coco arquette
teamed up for a cover of fleetwood mac's
1977 track
silver springs
that's her passion i would do anything
to continue to help
support women in this industry so she
doesn't have any the same issues and she
has all the opportunities that she
deserves